so let's say you were to go to a
restaurant and just out of curiosity you
want to see what what the makeup of the
ages at the restaurant are so you go
around the restaurant and you write down
everyone's age and so these are the ages
of everyone in the restaurant at that
moment
and so you're interested in in somehow
presenting this somehow visualizing the
distribution of the ages because you
want to just say well are there more
young people are there more teenagers
are there more middle aged people are
there more seniors here and so when you
just look at these numbers it really
doesn't give you a good sense of it it's
just a bunch of numbers
and so how could you do that
well one way to think about it is is to
put these ages into different buckets
and then to think about how many people
are there in each of those buckets or
sometimes someone might say how many in
each of those bins
so let's let's do that so let's do
buckets or categories
so
i like
sometimes it's called a bin
so the bucket i like to think of it more
of as a bucket
the bucket and then the number in the
bucket
the number
in the bucket
number
i'll just write the number whoops
it's the whoops
it's the number
it's the number in the bucket all right
so let's just make buckets let's make
them 10 year ranges so let's say the
first one is ages 0
to 9.
so how many people i know let me just
define all of the buckets here so the
next one is ages 10 to 19
then 20 to 29 then 30 to 39
and 40 to 49
50 to 59
make sure you can read that properly and
then you have 60 to 69 and i think that
covers everyone i don't see anyone 70
years old or older here so then how many
people fall into the zero to nine year
old bucket
what's going to be 1 2
five
six people fall into that bucket
how many people fall into the
how many people fall into the 10 to 19
year old bucket
well let's see
one
two 3
3 people
and i think you see where this is going
what about 20 to 29 so it's 1
5 people
five people fond of that bucket
all right what about 30 to 39
we have one
and that's it only one person in that 30
to 39
bin or bucket or category
all right what about 40 to 49 we have
one
two people
two people are in that bucket and then
50 to 59
so you have one
two people
two people and then finally
finally ages 60 to 69 let me do a
different color 60 to 69
there is one person
right over there
so this is one way of thinking about how
the ages are distributed but let's
actually make a a a
visualization of this and the
visualization that we're going to create
this is called a histogram
histogram
we're taking data that can take on a
whole bunch of different values we're
putting them into categories then we're
going to plot how many how many folks
are in each category how big are each of
those how big are each of those
categories and actually i wrote
histogram
i wrote histograph i should have written
so a histogram so let's do this
all right so on this axis let's see the
largest category has six
so this is the number
number of folks and it's going to go one
two
three four five six
one two three four five six
this the number and on this axis i'm
gonna make the buckets
the buckets and let me scroll up a
little bit now that i have my data here
i don't have to look at my data set
again
so i have one bucket this is going to be
the zero to nine bucket
right over here
zero to nine then i'm going to have the
three
actually let me just plot them since i
have my pen that color so in zero to
nine there are six people
zero to nine
there are six people so i'll just plot
it like that and then we have the 10 to
19 there are three people so 10
to 19 there are three people so i'll do
a bar
like this
then
20 to 29 i have five people
20 to 29
which is going to be this one just
getting i'm writing too big
so 20 to 29 this is gonna be this bar
there's five people
five people there
so it'll look like this
i should have made the bars wide enough
so i could write below them but i've
already that train has already left
all right
all right then 30 to 39 i'll try to
write smaller 30 to 39 that's going to
be this bar right over here we have one
person
one person
and then we have 40 to 49 we have two
people
40 to 49
two people
so it looks like this
40 to 49 two people almost there 50 259
we have two people 50 to 59 we also have
two people
so that's that right over there that's
this category and then finally 60 to 69
we have one person
we have one person and what i have just
constructed i took our data
i took our data i put it into buckets
that are kind of representative of the
categories i care about zero to nine is
kind of young kids 10 to 19. i guess you
could call them adolescents or roughly
teenagers although obviously if you're
10 you're not quite a teenager yet and
then all the different age groups and
then when i i counted the number in each
bucket and i and i plotted it now i can
visually get a sense of how are the ages
distributed in this restaurant this must
be some type of a restaurant that gives
away toys or something because there's a
lot of younger people maybe it's very
family friendly so every adult that
comes in maybe there's a lot of young
adults with with kids and or maybe
grandparents up here and they just bring
a lot of kids to this restaurant
so it gives you a view of what's going
on here just a lot of kids here a lot
fewer senior citizens so once again this
is just a way of visualizing things we
took a lot of data that can take
multiple data points instead of plotting
each data point like we might do in a
dot plot instead of saying how many
one-year-olds are there well there's
only one one-year-old how many
three-year-olds are there's only one
three-year-old that wouldn't give us
much information we just have like these
single dots if we were doing a dot plot
but as a histogram we're able to put
them into buckets and we're just like
hey you know generally between ages 0
and 9 we have six people and so you see
that plotted out just like that and
obviously this doesn't apply just to
ages of people in a restaurant it
applies to all sorts of data that you
might want to collect and observe